hi good afternoon everyone it's my very
great pleasure to welcome you to our
second company of scholars lecture this
year this is our chance to hear from our
colleagues all the interesting work
that's being that's going on on campus
today we have Emily Greenwood to speak
with us she's a professor of classics
and currently also the director of
undergraduate studies in the department
emily trained at cambridge university
receiving her BA MPhil and PhD degrees
from Cambridge after which she was a
lecturer in Greek for several years at
st. Andrews University before joining
the Yale faculty in 2009 her research
interests are rooted in ancient Greek
historiography and Greek prose
literature of the 5th and 6th centuries
BCE but she has very interesting
wide-ranging interests that carry her
from ancient times into 20th century
modern times and the influence of Greek
literature on current events or current
much more current to us anyway she's the
author of two books lucidity Xand
shaping the shaping of history published
in 2006 and afro Greeks dialogues
between Anglophone Caribbean literature
and classics in the 20th century which
was published in 2010 and for which she
was awarded the Runciman prize one of
several prizes she's she's won and she's
currently working on a third book called
classics a beginner's guide and is the
author of many articles Emily also
taught in the first Mellon concentration
courses of course here at Yale that you
may be familiar with and the theme was
technologies of knowledge which she
taught with Francesco Cassetti and the
film and Media Studies department and
with FAS Dean Tamar Gendler of the
philosophy department so today professor
Greenwood will compare through Sidda T's
idea of the Great War and that of course
was the Peloponnesian War with the
figure of the Great War in British prose
fiction and memoirs of the first
world war in her talk how to write award
facilities and British First World War
literature welcome thank you very much
for that introduction Dean Cooley and
I'd like to thank you and Robin
Ladouceur for organizing this series and
for setting this particular lecture up
and above all warm thanks to the
audience here today I can see many many
many busy friends and colleagues in the
audience it's a great honor to give a
company of scholars lecture and in the
spirit of the lecture series I've chosen
a topic that spans several different
disciplines and which ideally should be
tackled by a company rather than a lone
individual scholar so I'm particularly
looking forward to the discussion after
the talk in the era of the digital
humanities I cherished the quite quaint
sounding idea of a company of scholars
whose work is with our own bodies
digitally corporally mentally and
collectively as a more knowing body in
order to conceive of and explore ever
expanding and ever shifting fields of
knowledge thinking about the individual
scholars role in all of this I came
across the term into memory used in
computer science to describe if I
understand it correctly and I quote
large scale highly survivable and
available storage systems made up of
widely distributed processors that are
individually unreliable or trustworthy
with the overall system nevertheless
secure I don't want to characterize
scholars in the humanities or scholars
in any field as individually unreliable
that would be taking the strategy of
rhetorical self debasement too far but
what I cling to in that quotation is the
interdependency of different disciplines
it's the bit about the overall system
nevertheless secure that inspires me
today I guess you could also say that
speaking in a company of scholars series
I have a slight performance anxiety
given that the last lecture in this
series
was literally given by a company of
scholars the great team of Valerie
Hansen Mary Miller and Anders wind off
on the theme Ithaca circa 1000 so let me
preface what I'm going to say by
offering a bit of background as to why
I've chosen this topic a one-level it's
part of a current project which I'm
calling comparing Thucydides where I'm
staging a series of dialogues between
Thucydides and different authors in
antiquity and modernity at another level
the material that I'm presenting today
is part of a larger thinking through of
the narrative structures and historical
myths and by myths I don't mean fictions
as such I mean stories through which
history is transmitted so the narrative
structures and historical myths that we
live by in the 21st century my own and
specifically of course in the case of
this lecture I'm going to be talking
about narrative structures and
historical myths of the first world war
my own first partial and subjective
encounters with a collective memory and
history making the first world war
derived from the 1980s and 90s when I
came across the subject of the first
world war in the school curriculum in
subtle fragmented but persistent ways
the schools I attended in Britain
I saw memorials to the Fallen about the
school grounds which inscribed roles of
former pupils who had given their lives
in the Great War this was soon followed
for me by the realization that the
literature of the First World War
was deadly serious within this
curriculum and in some sense hallowed at
the third school I attended for example
pupils who misbehaved might be set as
punishment
Tennyson's charge of the Light Brigade
the perm of 1854 relating to the Crimean
War and they'd have to memorize it as
punishment or write it out a hundred
times but the literature and the poems
of the First World War would never be
abused in this way the fourth school
that I attended had a very strong
culture of voluntary service an
afternoon a week would be devoted to
service and one got to choose from a
menu of different forms of service one
of which was an organization
called the combined cadet force CCF this
was a program sponsored by the British
Ministry of Defence I ended up in the
Royal Air Force division of this
combined Cadet forces a stents would be
the rationale of this program is was and
is because it still exists is to instill
discipline leadership and strength of
character in students through a soft
introduction to military service I
didn't have any particular affinity for
the Armed Forces at the time but I think
and I'm fully aware of the fal ability
of my own memory in thinking this I
think that I drifted in to this combined
cadet force because of the solemn
impression of the lists of the Fallen
not to mention monuments and village
greens and town squares as I was growing
up but being taken to a shooting range
and being made to shoot at a silhouette
of a soldier immediately put me off as
did the fact that my afro wouldn't fit
under the beret that was part of our
regulation uniform so I had to cut a
slot in the back of my beret and of
course I promptly failed the first
inspection on parade I've begun with
these vignettes not in any way to claim
familiarity or affinity with the
historical experience of the First World
War as it was experienced by combatants
and civilians I'm talking about Britain
which is just one of many many theaters
and country's horrific experienced by
this war nor if I told these vignettes
to insert myself as an heir to the
legacy of the British experience of the
first world war but rather is an act of
disclosure so as to why I might be
susceptible to the complex politics and
poetics of what a Yale colleague
professor Jay winter has termed the
crowded field of the historical
membranes of World War one in the
centennial of the first world war I
think that men and women around the
world in all countries in all of the
countries that were involved in the war
and who were conscious of its vast
losses a wrestling with the burden and
the a Perea the despondency and
imponderable 'ti of memory the a per ear
of trying to
figure out an appropriate attitude of
memory with a gue regard to the global
war and our relationship with a past for
which we do not exist and in using that
phrase a past for which we do not exist
I'm twisting a famous phrase of Joseph
Brodsky where he spoke about classical
antiquity in the sense that while
antiquity exists for us in modernity we
for antiquity do not in the context of
the centenary observation of the first
world war which has revived debates
about the politics and protocols of
memory in the different countries
affected by the conflict I've often
asked myself what my discipline classics
and specifically the sub-discipline of
Greek historiography knows that might
usefully be part of a larger
conversation about the commemoration of
the first world war
recent scholarship has furnished some
excellent answers to this question I've
been particularly inspired for instance
by Elizabeth VanDerveer work stand in
the trench Achilles classical receptions
in British poetry of the First World War
but Greek historiography hasn't been
prominent in this discussion although in
political thought and international
relations facilities as history is a
familiar companion text for analyzing
Wars of the 20th century he's used for
example as a dialogue piece for the
first and second world wars the Korean
War the Cold War more generally and the
first Gulf War but when we turned to the
literature of war in the 20th century
facilities hasn't been an obvious
presence whether in Britain or elsewhere
in this lecture I'm not going to try to
argue that Thucydides is an important
presence in British First World War
literature
instead I'm going to use a comparison
between a select group of British First
World War novels and memoirs to refocus
the debate on the way in which this
literature negotiates the discredited
greatness of the first war so-called
great war in Britain I'll argue that
Thucydides is account of a self-styled
great war the wall between the Athenians
and the Peloponnesians in the 5th
century BCE reinvents the idea of the
great war in
and literature reacting against the
version of the great war as epic
familiar from Homer's Iliad and I'll
also argue that a study of the narrative
tropes and linguistic devices that
Thucydides users to construct his Great
War helped to tease out structures of
narrative and meaning in British First
World War literature that are
characterized by disillusionment about
the Great War this dialogue with
acidities adds a supplement to
prevailing arguments that explain the
ironic paradigm in terms of literary
modernism and disillusionment with
contemporary history so I'm going to try
and use the dialogue with you Sid ''tis
to disturb conventional periodization
and ways of explaining how a particular
set of novels are characterized by
disenchantment with the war I should say
as an aside that to focus a topic on the
Great War in a dialogue about the Great
War is of course parochial in many ways
insofar as the nomenclature of the Great
War is used predominantly in Britain
like Hong gars Liu's far less in France
and dacosta's Krieg far less in Germany
so its parochial in that sense but I
think that there's a more generalizable
aspect here in that the underlying
question of the historiographical
ethics of war writing is one that
applies to the literature and
commemoration of all wars in all places
and particularly how this war literature
navigates the question of heroic
paradigm of greatness that shifts over
the course of the unfolding of a war to
a tragic paradigm of greatness in
scholarship on British literature of the
First World War the argument this is
that this literature treats greatness as
an ironic construct and a construct that
was ripe for satire is associated above
all with Paul Fussell's work the Great
War and modern memory published in 1975
since then the cultural turn and
literary studies has challenged for
those arguments about the wars texts and
his corresponding attention to the
self-conscious litter enos of the war in
works written overwhelmingly by men of
the officer class
while this challenge and correction of
Fussell is important
it hasn't undermined or reversed his
insight that the works that constitute
the Canon and I am aware that we're
talking artificially here about a Canon
the works that have come to constitute
the Canon of British first world war
literature subscribed to an ironic
reading of the war is still very much a
current argument
I'm not going to tackle the important
debate about the degree to which these
ironic and disillusioned representations
were more broadly representative of a
prevailing tendency in the collective
memory in Britain of the first world war
instead I want to examine the way in
which the ironic mode links First World
War literature in Britain to a larger
metal genre of critical war literature
and I'm going to pose affinities and
similarities with a stuck structural
conundrum that Thucydides was faced with
in writing up his war namely how to
reconcile an argument about the
greatness of the war that he was writing
in terms of its scale and importance
with the realization that its greatness
was simultaneously a property of tragedy
and was measured in loss so I've
suggested that in the Western
historiographical tradition Thucydides
invents the figure of the great war a
figure characterized by an emphasis on
the unprecedented scale and significance
of the war being narrated at the level
of narrative this the acidity and Great
War is structured around a colossal
reversal of expectations
it's underscored by the literary trope
of irony as I've stared and
stylistically this idea of the great war
in Thucydides is conveyed through
rhetorical amplification repeatedly
through the use of superlative
adjectives in the description of this
war in fact it's and Thucydides that we
get the idea of the great war as an
inherently comparative figure in
Thucydides as case the principle
comparison as I've said is with the
Trojan War of Homeric epic which he
treats as a semi-fictional war and then
the other comparison of course with
Herodotus Herodotus's narrative of the
Persian War
in the preface to his histories
Herodotus had claimed that one of his
aims and I quote is to preserve the fame
of the important and remarkable
achievements the ergo megalithic item
aster produced by both Greeks and
non-greeks
ie Herodotus had claimed that his
subject matter was great or important
but not that it was the greatest subject
matter conceivable conversely having
introduced his subject matter as a Great
War the acidities quickly establishes it
or moves to establish it we can
obviously resist accepting his rhetoric
moves to establish it as a greater war
than any other conflict ever written
about I quote facilities of Athens wrote
the War of the Peloponnesians and the
Athenians how they waged it against each
other he began writing it it's very
outset in the expectation that this
would be a great war meganta assessed I
and more worthy of account than any
previous ones he based his judgment on
the grounds that both sides came into
the war at the height of their powers
and in a full state of military
readiness and he also saw that the rest
of the Greek world had either taken
sides right at the start or was now
planning to do so this was certainly the
greatest ever upheaval amongst the
Greeks and one which affected a good
part of the barbarian world - even you
could say most of mankind so a
completely preemptive Universal claim to
the greatness of his subject in respect
I continued in respect of the preceding
period and the still remoter past the
length of time that elapsed made it
impossible to ascertain clearly from
what happened but from the evidence I
find I can trust in pushing my inquiries
back as far as possible I judge the
early events were not on the same scale
either as regards their wars or in other
respects he reinforces that soon after
by saying conceding that although men
always think that the war that they at
the moment engaged in is the greatest
one and when it's over they're even more
impressed by earlier ones nevertheless
for those who look at the actual facts
this war the one he's in a rating
the one I'm narrating in the voice of
the feasted Indian narrator will prove
greater than earlier once this rhetoric
of the singular greatness of the Athena
Peloponnesian War is amplified in
another famous passage at raptor 23 of
book one of these two diseases history
where he stresses the unprecedented
degree and scale of suffering
characterized in the war I find this
particular passage particularly
suggestive for the way in which it uses
comparison to reiterate or underscore
the idea of incomparability this
particular conflict was characterized by
the fact that people suffered things
unprecedented in any comparable period
of time facilities as calibration of the
greatness of his war and indeed his
rhetorical construction of the greatness
then throws down the gauntlet for
subsequent Greek historiography all this
is well known and much discussed in
scholarship on Thucydides the narrative
techniques that characterize his
narration briefly outlined above are
omnipresent when we turn to the
literature of the first world war in
Britain although grammatically the
positive degree of the adjective in the
phrase the Great War his eye has
unmistakable sorry although when we use
the term the phrase the Great War the
the positive degree of the adjective
great is unmarked
it has unmistakable connotations of
superlative miss the Great War is in a
sense the greatest war and it's because
I guess because of the singularity
implied by the pronoun the Great War as
in the greatest war and we only have to
think about the way in which this in
main creature has stuck to concede the
effectiveness of the device of
rhetorical amplification in this phrase
in so far as the Thucydides conception
of the Great War is inherently
comparative it necessarily undercuts
itself in facilities this comes clearly
in book 1 chapter 10 in a famous
hypothetical thought experiment
where he asked his readers to consider
what people of the future would conclude
about Sparta's power in the second half
of the fifth century BCE
what would they conclude about sparta
based on surveying its archaeological
ruins just suppose he asked his reader
the city of sparta were wiped out and
all that were left were it shrines and
the foundations of its buildings i think
that years later future generations
would find it hard to believe that its
power matched up to its reputation in
entering into comparison across
historical time facilities engages the
impermanence of magnitude in the present
although his war is allegedly the
greatest war ever in terms of resources
deployment of forces events and
consequent fallout as the rhetoric of
the passage that I've just read makes
clear this comparative historical
perspective also implies the contingent
nature of the greatness of the war in
other words all this physical greatness
all the resources being poured into the
war which are spoken about at length in
the first book of the history by the
different states involved all of this
doesn't translate necessarily into
ultimate success in the war that
facilities and rates it's not the state
Athens with the most resources it's not
the greatest state in physical terms
that ultimately ends victorious this
observation ties into facilities as
complex treatments of the instability of
power of Dunamis within the history
looking behind the statement at chapter
10 of book 1 is a famous remark by
Herodotus book 1 chapter 5 of his
histories where he says his reader that
he will cover minor and major
settlements equally because those
settlements that were important in the
past have diminished in significance by
now and those which were great in my own
time were small in times past in
Herodotus histories written roughly
contemporaneously with acidities Athens
was a hegemonic power when Herodotus was
writing in the sense that it was
encroaching all over the Greek world
but in Herodotus's history's the version
that he chooses to write he goes back
into the past where Athens is a small
state it's small both from the
perspective of the Persians who invade
Greece and it's small and fragile from
the perspective of the other Greek
States who watch many of whom sit on the
sidelines to wait and see how its clash
with Persia will play out Herodotus is
historical research then relies on
criteria of magnitude that are
inherently relative the largest or
greatest city or army is only so in
comparison to other cities and armies
past and present following the scholar
Merrick wachowski I would argue that
Herodotus is relative ization
of historical judgments about greatness
is one of the generic traits that
characterizes the emerging genre of
history in the Greek world and it's one
that informs two Citadis is ironic an
equivocal conception of greatness
wherein Thucydides the greatness of the
war is event and subject doesn't reside
in the fragile or contingent greatness
of either of the states involved in the
war this trend in Greek historiography I
think bequeaths an interesting legacy
for a critical tradition of war writing
there's legacy in other words is the
insight that the greatness of the work
will rely in part on the authors
critical detachment and distance from
prevailing conventions or scales of
greatness there's something decidedly
anti epic or anti heroic about this
strand of War writing and this is long
before we get to the anti heroism of the
disillusioned British First World War
literature I mentioned that few Citadis
is irenna zation of the greatness of his
great war in which the greatness becomes
increasingly tragic as the narrative
proceeds is suggestive for understanding
the recurrence of irony as a governing
trope in retrospective First World War
literature written in the 1920s and 30s
the further argument that I want to make
on which I can only begin to sketch here
is that the works that have this ironic
structure
British literature are often ones that
are overtly preoccupied with what I'll
call historiographical ethics the how
and why of the treatment of the
historical past with respect to the
truth or the reality of lived historical
experience although avowedly and
inescapably fictional by its very nature
all First World War literature is
implicated in discourses of truth and
history as George Parfitt noted in his
book fiction of the first world war
men and women who write about the great
war are seeking for whatever reasons to
present some kind of truth about a
conflict which was fought in several
theaters across thousands of miles over
several years with vast armies puffit
goes on to observe that this
historically oriented genre results in
interesting hybrid crossings of diary
memoir history biography autobiography
and novel while many scholars and
Paphitis just 1 have remarked on the
interpenetration of fact and fiction in
British first world war literature I
think what still remains to be done is
to pay concerted attention to the
systematic hysteria graphic concerns and
the historiographical
in post-war First World War literature
and I can only offer a brief sketch of
this topic here I'll do so under three
headings firstly the novelist as
historian secondly discourses of truth
and fiction and thirdly history as
monument for the purposes of comparison
with Thucydides I'd like to tease out
how this group of writers
consciously imitate and sometimes parody
historical discourse these writers are
mindful of the preemptory claims of
history to authoritative accounts of the
past and yet they challenge the scope
and legitimacy of historical
representation many of them adopt the
pose of the novelist as historian ap
Herbert's novel the secret battle
published in 1919 which is framed as a
fictional biography of a fictional
character Harry Penrose but based on the
experience of a naval sub-lieutenants
Edwyn diet begins with the sentence I am
going to write down some of the history
of Harry Penrose the gist of Herbert's
novel is a narrative vindication of an
officer who served in the Gallipoli
campaign in 1915 and subsequently did a
tour of duty in the Western Front in
France all the while struggling with
nerves and fear only to be
court-martialed and shot for cowardice
for seeking shelter with his men during
a doomed offensive while the title of
Herbert's novel is the secret history
Herbert frequently used sorry the secret
battle Herbert frequently uses the
phrase the secret history in the novel
as a metaphor for his Vindicator II
narrative and in the closing stages of
the novel he sets up an opposition
between the official judicial procedures
of the court-martial and military
history versus the inaccessible secret
history that would reveal the truth
about Harry Penrose is suffering the
role of novelist as historian is
articulated explicitly rather than
implicitly in Herbert explicitly in Ford
Madox Ford's memoir it was the
nightingale published in the UK in 1933
and the u.s. in 1934 reflecting on the
construction of his famous tetralogy of
First World War models published
collectively as parades end Ford Madox
Ford ruminates on the inspiration and
motivation behind this tetralogy the
work that at that time and now I wanted
to see done was something on an immense
scale a little cloudy an immediate
attack but with salient points and the
final impression extraordinarily clear I
wanted the novelist in fact to appear in
his really proud position as historian
of his own time veera Britain's test
forwards to testament of youth published
in the same year 1933 as Ford's memoir
presents her own memoir of the first
world war as an attempt to write history
in terms of personal life and in terms
of putting the life of an ordinary
individual in its niche in contemporary
history
the idea that the important literary
work to be done was historical
counter-narrative providing an urgent
supplement to what past for the history
of the First World War
resounds throughout all of the corpus of
novels that I'm looking at here the
narrator of Richard dallington 's
sardonically entitled death of a hero
published in 1929 offers a cynical
commentary on retrospective histories of
the First World War
all this time the war was drawing
steadily nearer probably it had become
certain since 1911
though most people were taken quite
unaware why did it happen who was
responsible questions which have been
interminably debated already and will
furnish exultant historians with
controversial material for generations
to come
already one foresees the creation of
chairs in the history of the First World
War to be set up in whatever civilized
countries remain in existence after the
next one
alling Tain's novel uses many of the
same criteria of varied Akala tea and
documentary realism as historical
accounts but insists on the autonomy of
fiction this commitment to the autonomy
of fiction is reflected in Ernest
Hemingway's endorsement for Frederick
Manning's 1929 novel the middle parts of
fortune which was published in 1930 in
unexpurgated form as her private Swede
and I include Frederick Manning here
it's an Australian author but he served
within a British regiment and wrote
about the British experience of the war
in his introduction to an italic
anthology of war writing entitled men at
war published in 1942 Hemingway wrote
that her privates we was and I quote the
finest and noblest book of men in war
that I've ever read I read it over once
each year to remember how things really
were so that I will never lie to myself
nor to anyone else about them
Hemingway's artful discourse on the
Virata criticality of fiction chimes
with revived debates about the fictive
nosov fusillade eases history that were
going on in classical scholarship at the
beginning of the 20th century
in the preface to a work entitled
Thucydides myth hystericus published in
1907 the scholar Francis Cornford had
written and I quote it's possible
however even for a writer of history to
be something much better than
trustworthy it's possible for a writer
of history to be an artist before
proceeding to expound a notorious
argument about how Thucydides wrote his
history under the inspiration of Greek
tragedy the most comprehensive imitation
of historical and historiographical
discourse that I've been able to find in
the critical disillusioned literature in
Britain of the first world war occurs in
the foreword to Vera Britain's preface
to her memoir testament of youth we can
subdivide this discourse into a number
of themes and I'll really just read out
a sense of the piling up of this
historical discourse in her preface Vera
Brittain writes about the exact truth
offering some element of truth writing
as truthfully as I could she describes
the burden of her experience as too real
and wants to give a real account to
write about things as they really were
she engages in a lot of
historiographical self-fashioning
presenting the work as an attempt to
write history an attempt to put on
record a contribution to contemporary
history and says that it's backed up by
detached reconstruction and
retrospective reflections above all she
puts it forward to the reader as a
testament she engages in documentary ISM
referring to sources on which the
account has made old letters and diaries
documents and records she also speaks
about the value and utility of the work
hoping that she will produce something
that might be of value some elements of
youth usefulness or something worthwhile
she grounds her account in discourses of
memory invoking memory and hoping to
challenge that too easy to comfortable
relapsed into forgetfulness she also
searches for historical meaning hoping
that her Testament will explain or
convey what the First World War meant to
people of her generation that it will be
exposition of the wars public
significance that it will comment on
worldwide events and finally she has the
address to posterity that we have come
to expect in the historiographical
tradition in the West she speaks of our
successors she speaks at the depleted
generation which has to make the present
an endeavor to mold the future and she
also refers to history's most grievous
repetitions one way of explaining this
piling up and it's I guess much more
prolific than that we find in the other
parrot ex that a company is this
disillusioned first world war British
literature one way of explaining it
would be to see it in terms of Vera
Brittain putting forward very
self-consciously a woman's history of
the war and leaning on the authority of
historiographical discourse as a way of
presenting her work in the preface but I
think that's not fully accurate because
she also intertwines this discourse with
a reminder that this is her own very
private story and she takes the reader
through the genesis of a testament of
youth explaining how in an earlier
iteration it started as a novel and how
she contemplated just republishing her
diaries kept during the war which was
subsequently published posthumously
so she contemplated republishing her
diaries changing the names but then says
that no she's very consciously settled
for this hybrid form of a memoir that
blends historical experience with
fiction works that are either actual or
pseudo memoirs sustain a constant
commentary on their own documentary
methods what I've been calling
documentary ism they frequently refer to
the diaries letters transcripts and
interviews on which they base their
accounts of the first world war secrets
assumes three-part memoir written in the
persona of George sir Stern and
published in 1928 1930 in 1936 is a good
example of this in the third and last
volume of this series
sure stands progress Sassoon's alter-ego
george Hurston comments wryly on a
sermon
by an army bishop reassuring the reader
that his version is accurate because in
a spare notebook I wrote down the main
parts of his sermon so I'm able to
transcribe what might otherwise be
accurately inaccurately remembered
insofar as their offering alternative
versions to those contained in
government reports these writers
fluctuate between a commitment to the
pleura vocality of the past and a sense
that representation of the war in
literature is a zero-sum game in 1933
Vera Brittain commented on the boom in
war literature and described her own
intervention in publishing her Testament
as a late entry into the field in the
preface to his memoir of the first world
war entitled undertones of war published
in 1928
Edwin Blondin asks his addressee why
should I not write it where the pronoun
it denotes both his accounts the volume
that the reader is reading and the war
of which it is an account another
pronoun is important here too in Blunden
Steckler ation the authorial in naira
toriel I why when so many other literary
figures had turned their hand to writing
the war should Blondin be excluded not
least among these figures of course was
the poet Wilfred owned whose poems
Blunden would edit for a new collection
that would appear in 1931 London's first
sentence why should I not write it
rehearses the problematic of war writing
what I've called the historiographical
ethics and we encounter the same
problematic at the beginning of few
Citadis as history fook added s Hassan
niacin arab state on polym on lucidity
is the athenian wrote the War of the
Peloponnesians and the Athenians to
write the war is simultaneously to
record it and in the process of writing
to distort it to substitute a textual
version of the war for the under a table
totality of the war and the experiences
of all who lived through it and who died
in it
but as the elite linguistic turn in
historiography has made abundantly clear
there's no war without narration even
the it in blonde UNS why should i not
write it is already pre-written and pre
narrated as hayden white remarks they
historical entities become historical
only to the extent to which they are
represented as subjects of a
specifically historical kind of writing
Blunden himself got involved in the
polemics about which version of the war
was most representative attacking Robert
Graves autobiographical memoir goodbye
to all that published in 1929 as a
misleading and vicious debunking of
honest soldier II and the values that
London himself identified with the rank
and file of the British Army in the
First World War in his biography of
Edmund London Barry Webb describes an
evening specifically the seventh of
November 1929 where siegfried sassoon
and edmund Blunden sat down together an
annotated Blunden manuscript copy of
graves as goodbye to all that with
marginal corrections and criticisms this
manuscript is now in the burgh
collection of New York Public Library
there was also a private copy that
belonged to siegfried sassoon with his
annotations which sold privately at
auction in 2007 so that's a particularly
explicit version of the polemics of the
historiographical ethics of the First
World War
while unable to see and predict the
Second World War these novels and
memoirs a time sensitive in the sense
that they fear the recurrence of war and
decry the possibility that future
generations might suffer what their
generation had suffered they all seek in
their different ways to hand on a
warning and testimony to the next
generation and to an indefinite and
obscure posterity Ford Madox Ford writes
that in undertaking parades end he went
against his own bias against novels
written with a purpose seeking to write
a work I'm quoting to write a work that
should have for its purpose the
obviating of all future Wars the
solidity in
that facilities set down his account of
the war between the Athenians and the
Peloponnesians to be an everlasting
possession at Catera si a
is one that resonates strongly with the
concerns of these critical First World
War writers in the study of war imagined
Samuel Heins examined the troop of anti
monuments in pessimistic British First
World War literature what is interesting
to me about this a new monomer anti
monumental anti monumental ISM that
Heinz describes is that on the one hand
it offers a savage critique of official
forms of commemoration while at the same
time holding itself forward as a more
appropriate monument to the experience
of individual men and women the preface
to Richard Olding Tain's book death of a
hero published in 1929 declares his work
as really a trendy a memorial in its
ineffective way to a generation which
hoped much strove honestly and suffered
deeply in the first pages of the novel
the narrator reproduces the casualty
lists citation for his fictional
protagonist George Winterbourne
commenting sardonically that
Winterbourne got his meat ration of
headstone in France and then proceeds to
contest the value and relevance of the
official record of George's death I
quote hauling ttan as a narrator I can't
claim that I'd set up any altar to the
deceased George in my heart but I truly
believe that I'm the only person left
alive who ever thinks of him before
exploding a few pages later the death of
a hero
what mockery what bloody can't what
sickening putrid can't they're all so
fascinating instances in this critical
pessimistic British First World War
literature where the alternative
monuments of fiction are endorsed as
true monuments by public figures ap
Herbert's the secret battle which I've
already mentioned published in 1919 was
reissued in 1929 with a preface by
Winston Churchill which endorsed the
fictional biography of her
penrose as and I quote a monument to the
agony not of one but of millions
standing impassive in marble to give its
message to all Wayfarers who pass it
speaks to the uninformed to the
unimaginative to the headstrong and to
the short memory to folk who need a word
of warning on their path as Elizabeth
Vandiver has shown there's a paradox
about British First World War literature
and its relationship with classics on
the one hand there are copious allusions
to Greek and Roman classical literature
which I haven't been talking about here
and these allusions indicate the extent
to which classical myths and literature
were used to respond to experiences of
warfare but at the same time in this
literature there's a deep distrust and
cynicism about the usefulness and
relevance of classics for the present
day more than that there's a suspicion
of the malign influence of classics in
the present day in the early decades of
the 20th century as Vera Brittain puts
it in her memoir and not quoting exactly
but paraphrasing of her experience of
being an undergraduate at Oxford before
she left to become a voluntary
age-division nurse in the Western Front
why spend so much time translating
Caesar and other passages of Latin about
people killing each other when one's
compatriots are killing each other
within a hundred and fifty miles of
where you're doing the translation but
the same Vera Britain also turns in her
memoir at several instances to Homeric
epic as a source of consolation for the
loss of her fiance in the law war and
later for the loss of her brother in
many instances elsewhere officers in the
British Army are characterized by their
intellectual complacency where a shallow
and imperfect knowledge of Latin is used
as a pretext for superior learning I
quote an example from Frederick
Manning's her privates we where an
officer called Evans as described as an
educated pre-war public school boy which
means that he remembered half a dozen
Latin tags could
a few on grammatical phrases in French
knew a little history of England and had
a correct accent this passage I think is
typical of the deep suspicion of the
role that classics might have had
ensuring up the idiocies and hypocrisy
z' of the governing classes in britain
and what were perceived as failures in
military intelligence in the field but
as with Vera Britain's ambiguous
attitude to classics ancient Greek
authors also in this literature provide
a source of creative inspiration and
counter myths to rival contemporary
historical fictions for all Denton
London Britain Ford Herbert and Sassoon
the question of the continuing
significance of classics was also a way
of confronting the significance and
meaning of their own times and their
recent historical experience in the
light of history the memoirs and novels
that I've been talking about contemplate
their own relation to the past often
returning to the distant past of
classical antiquity and insofar as they
offer their own account of a past war to
future readers they also insert
themselves into this historical relay as
well and this raises the question that
if the classics of antiquity and the
works that recount them are outmoded and
debunked in the present day what are the
stakes or implications for their own
versions of a past war projected into
the future I'll end with an example and
it's my only example in this talk of an
explicit few theta-d anism in British
first world war literature this comes
from Guy Chapman's novel a passionate
prodigality fragments of autobiography
published in 1933 this autobiographical
novel ends in disgust with complete
contempt for British society and the
apparent aims of the war and it
expresses disillusionment in the form of
a quotation in Greek very unusual in
British first world war literature to
have a non translated quotation this
quotation comes from Thucydides is
million dialogue from book 5 at
acidities as history where Athenian
envoy's are depict
did spelling out Athens aggressive
Imperial aims to the millions from the
island of Melos who were trying to
resist incorporation into Athens as
Empire the line that Chapman quotes is
from Thucydides book 5 chapter 91 and I
quote from Jeremy Minot's translation so
this is the Athenian speaking well as
for this empire of ours if that came to
an end we would not be too daunted by
its passing the threat to the defeated
comes not from other ruling powers like
the Spartans though our dispute here is
not with them but from their subjects
should they be the ones to take on their
former masters and get the upper hand on
the last page of his novel Chapman
writes our civilization was being torn
in pieces before our eyes England was
said to be a country fit only for profit
ears to live in yesterday will pro slack
a dime on us hemming Oregon many of us
were growing bitter thank you
that was the beginning of the would you
try to repeat the question um so the
question here from Professor Krauss
when I called up that slide showing the
beginning of HB Herbert's the secret
battle where the narrator says I'm going
to write something of the history of
Harry Penrose yes yes if you leave aside
the preface from Churchill which was
added later in a way is is more
comparable to Thucydides I think that's
what you're suggesting because the
preface is embedded in the main work
rather than being a paratext in the form
of a prologue and some of these works
have several prologues yeah I think
that's right and in my attempt to sort
of try and sketch this dialogue between
acidities and this corpus of literature
I've obviously been stressing points of
contact rather than in commencer
abilities by calling this talk how to
write a war I don't want to imply in any
way that Thucydides is normative for a
metal genre of war literature
I think the fascinating thing is the
other part of the conversation how when
we turn to this particular corpus we
could also look at contemporary war
writing the ways in which the authors
negotiate the strategies of narration of
war right back to facilities and expose
what he chooses not to do and the lack
of preface 'as parrot X that we we
wrestle with in looking at ancient
literature you know call to mind the
sort of huge sense of golf and
incomparability gesture ethnicity
suggested what what Herman is writing is
a fragment is a is impartial was a very
tiny part which fits with the idea just
rather than trying to write the greatest
war just a little bit of the history of
many members yes and I think there the
tension then becomes between the
singularity of the story and its strong
authoritative claims to representation
or XM priority that it can be
extrapolated or multiplied out to speak
for millions and you know again the way
in which you put that question reminds
us of the fact that the acidities is a
person in the war he writes it in some
sense on the authority of having been a
general and yet that person disappears
in his account of the war facilities
describes himself as two different
people in his own account
are there any figures who are comparable
to two lucida these
and having had significant contact with
both sides for example I'm thinking of
thee of the German names that you see in
the lists of war dead in British
universities who returned home to play
against thee against the British art is
there any literature comparable in a
specific sense of having been but
written by somebody who actually has
significant contact with both sides can
you just say the question so um
professor beers has asked to what extent
in this sort of and this is my admission
the corpus that I've been talking about
is a very very limited collection of
post war novels and memoirs looking back
on the first world war which I've
treated as a sort of particular corpus
because they are linked by the sort of
disillusionment with which they approach
the war and because many of the writers
are in conversation with each other and
conscious of each other's work in this
corpus that I've been talking about are
there any examples of authors who like
Thucydides claim to have had exposure to
different sides in the war not in the
ones that I've been talking about that
doesn't mean they don't exist not that I
know of the only analogy I can think of
is the way in which contact or touch or
encounters with enemy combatants make it
into the novels as a way of not shoring
up objectivity Thucydides uses that
claim to say in 526 I saw the war from
both sides that's part of the authority
and impartiality of my account we don't
get that same stake played out in this
body of literature other than that an
encounter with the enemies sort of
reiterates
the sense of the absurdity and idiocy of
the conflict of killing people who in
the encounter were revealed to be as
human as you
in the movie a grande museum where
there's the beating of English
aristocracy with the with the chief of
the the German I forget the name of the
character a very famous actor ah that is
where they are in the way saying we
belong to the same class but now things
are really different and you have for
example the the German the German
officer speaks English breaks from the
French text there's that sort of goodbye
to all that yeah I mean I'm not sure
exactly ought to do that question which
I take more as an observation but I I
think that one of the legacies if I'm
thinking critically now of thinking
about facilities as a model of critical
war literature is the homogeneity of his
focus on the narration of a war that
although he talks about having seen the
war from different sides you know one
can sort of vocalize his narrative quite
clearly through the athenian perspective
and as you know there's a strong
tendency to play down those who fought
with the athenians but were not
Athenians the role of slaves from all
over the Greek world and beyond in the
conflict and here that in contemporary
critical historical accounts of the
first world war is work that's near only
laterally being done in thinking about
the broader spheres of empire and the
ways in which subjects are occluded in
these accounts you get sketches and
vignettes of foreigners it was a not
British French Belgian German Austrian
but foreigners from the Empire in these
novels I was struck in the passage you
mentioned
vicinities use of superlatives perhaps
exaggerated superlatives making it seem
as though this was unprecedented when we
know that our building wasn't but I was
struck by a passage in the book one
chapter 23 extra never before were so
many made men made exiles never before
was there so much slaughter which
includes the fronted I don't know
whether this is facilities or my not but
but what strikes me is the the fronted
negative adverb and the inversion and
the scale or the so many all of which
emphasize this you know compare
comparison with everything that has ever
come before and what it made me
immediately think of was the famous line
of world war one historian in the middle
of World War two never in the field of
human conflict was so much owed by so
many to so few which involves exactly
the same construction and I wonder
whether that any of that was actually in
the syntax and the facilities passage or
whether that was Minot's intervention in
the translation I mean off the top of my
head from what I remember about that
passage in Greek Thucydides 123 you do
have in the Greek that very stylized
negation which is a trope of of Greek
rhetoric and you know your comparison
with with was with Churchill and his
sort of negative try : in that famous
speech yeah I mean one could think
they're not just about fictional
accounts of the war but relays within
military rhetoric within the battlefield
and Churchill's use their in 1948 yes
yeah I didn't mean to say that
facilities in that particular instance
is using it ironically I mean this is
part of his strong rhetorical claim that
this is the most important war that has
ever taken place in the world to this
point but I was suggesting that that
then is undermined or begins to crumble
when you look elsewhere in his histories
at his consciousness of the contingency
and and relative ization of powers in
the broader sweep of history you know
it's very artificial in many ways to do
this kind of a historic eyes comparison
that I'm doing with the acidities and
this group of British First World War
writers one could equally think about
the way in which say Shakespeare is used
as a companion text for thinking about
the experience of war you know Frederick
Manning's her privates we every chapter
is prefaced with an epitaph from
Shakespeare you know there as well in
this broader project on comparing
facilities I'm interested in exultation
battle rhetoric in Shakespeare's history
plays and the ways in which they
rehearse tropes rhetorical exercises
from antiquity about the kinds of
speeches that you give on the field in
battle you know we have many examples of
those from Thucydides as well and in the
writers who I've been looking at the
British First World War writers one can
look at ways in which they consciously
parody those rhetorical models and
examples and yet are themselves invested
in the same rhetorical structure
well that's question sorry this I'd like
to try to like push back against the
suitability of these writers and Wars
for comparison I just wonder how you
would fit industrialization into your
analysis I mean lucidity is is making
the case for this is the greatest board
that's ever happened and yet wars that
follow after it probably resemble him
pretty pretty close indeed for a long
time whereas the wars that follow the
first world war are fundamentally
characteristically different from the
wars that preceded due largely to the
large-scale industrial technology
revolutions in the means of destruction
and killing and part of Russell's kind
of main point is that this
industrialization fundamentally changes
the ways in which Wars can be talked
about in the ways that can be remembered
and yeah I kind of how does this how
does this kind of point fit into your
analysis ok thank you so the question is
to what extent does the the sort of
shift in the military industrial
progression of warfare in the 20th
century from the first world war into
subsequent conflicts how does that pose
a problem for this sort of a historical
comparisons I'm doing with the war that
Thucydides covers and the writers
writing about the first world war and
I'm very interested in that question and
I thought a lot about it in relation to
Daniel picks book the war machine where
he talks about comparative histories of
warfare in the art of war and challenges
the idea that the First World War and
the Second World War
pose a sort of radical paradigm shift in
terms of thinking critically about the
history of warfare I mean obviously I
want to respect the difference in terms
of military technologies and conceptions
of warfare but yet at the same time
these authors who I'm discussing contain
lots of episodes in which characters in
the field of battle are in gay
in these very same questions you know at
the start of the war in 1914 where you
have Kings regulations dispatches sent
out to the field of battle telling you
to practice a battle formation or a
strategy that has may be remembered from
the burr war or from a war prior to that
and then catching up as the war proceeds
but some of them I'm thinking
particularly of a character general
Campion in the second novel in Fords
geology parades and that novel is no
more parades has this rant where he
writes a letter from the field of battle
back to the Secretary of War in London
trying to insist that you know in spite
of all the differences between all the
wars there are some points of good
generalship that remain constant in
terms of the need for a sort of singular
vision or good channels of communication
so I mean I agree with your point and
your your sort of challenge to what I've
been saying other than to say that I
don't think it's final or decisive this
is part of a negotiation that is going
on in this literature inserting itself
into this relay of writing about war and
thinking about where the differences
so I'd like to invite you to continue
this conversation at a reception in the
common room which is just a few steps
down the hall and I'd also like to thank
Emily for a wonderful seminar today